[Musik]
[Applaus]
sr werden war in den letzten monaten
öfter in den nachrichten und zwar meist
mit schlagzeilen die starke kontroversen
hervorriefen erinnert ihr euch zb an
novak djokovic den tennis spieler der
sich nicht gegen das corona virus impfen
lassen will und deswegen mit den
australischen behörden in konflikt
geriet wesentlich bedeutender wenn auch
nicht medial waren da schon die
prorussischen demonstration zu beginn
des russischen krieges gegen die ukraine
warum aber gibt es ist serbien
vergleichsweise viel unterstützung für
putin russland und umgekehrt wusstet ihr
dass auch putin sich stark für serbien
interessiert erinnert sich zum beispiel
an die rede in der er seine invasion
rechtfertigt achtet man auf diesen teil
erzählte in seiner rede all das unrecht
auf das der besten seit dem zerfall der
sowjetunion begangen hatte und dazu
zählt leider auch der nato einsatz
während der jugoslawienkriege ende der
90er jahre die jugoslawienkriege waren
eine serie von einigen der blutigsten
konflikte unserer zeit es handelte sich
im grunde um kriege im herzen europas
die kaum mehr als 20 jahre her sind und
serbien war damals der dominante teil
jugoslawiens
heute ist es ein land mit weniger als
sieben millionen einwohnern das weder
über immense wirtschaftliche oder
militärische macht verfügt noch
nennenswert bodenschätze vorzuweisen
hätte und obwohl es in seiner bedeutung
seitdem längst von kroatien slovenien
überholt wurde dürfen wir nicht
vergessen dass serbien eine nicht
unwesentliche rolle in der geschichte
gespielt hat schließlich haben dort
nicht nur die jugoslawienkriege ihren
ausgang genommen sondern zum beispiel
auch der erster weltkrieg die frage die
wir uns in diesem video stellen lautet
also warum war serbien in der
vergangenheit so ein pulverfass was ist
eigentlich während der jugoslawienkriege
passiert die meisten von euch noch in
den medien miterlebt haben bergen und
warum betonte putin diese immer wieder
in seinen reden wie sind die beziehungen
zwischen serbien und russland in diesem
video werden wir all diese fragen
natürlich beantworten bevor wir jedoch
zur tat schreiten müssen euch noch einen
neuen sponsor und seien durchaus
sinnvolles produkt vorstellen das
heutige video hat nämlich nord pass
ermöglicht worum es bei notpass geht nun
hast du ein überblick darüber wie viele
benutzernamen und passwörter du in
letzter zeit erstellt hast ich meine für
websites anwendungen e mail accounts und
so weiter ich wette dass du mittlerweile
riesige mengen an passwort dann für all
diese dienste angehäuft hast oder du
hast die kardinal sünde begangen und
dasselbe passwort mehr als einmal
benutzt kommt schon ich wette dass du
das schon mal getan hast so wie ich auch
es ist ja normal dass wir aufgrund von
zeitdruck oder schierer faulheit zu
einfach passwörter verwenden oder diese
gar recycelt und jetzt kommt die
unbequeme aber leider um so folgenreiche
wahrheit darüber in der heutigen zeit
können wir uns eine solche
nachlässigkeit immer weniger leisten
wirklich keiner von uns kann sie sich
leisten denn wir dürfen unsere
privatsphäre und unsere private
sicherheit nicht länger aufs spiel
setzen aber jetzt kommt die gute
nachricht mit nord pas kannst du
automatisch sichere passwörter für jedes
seine konten erstellen und sie an einem
ort speichern ohne dass du sie dir
merken muss und nicht nur das mit diesen
wirklich mieten passwort-manager kannst
du auch die daten in einer bank und
kreditkarten ganz einfach speichern und
wieder abrufen zu dass du beim online
bezahlen zeit spart und die kartendaten
bei den shops setzt speichern zu müssen
ok klingt kann es nicht nicht wahr das
geht jedoch noch einen schritt weiter
und schützt seine daten nicht nur passiv
sondern wirklich proaktiv mit einem
ganzen arsenal von security features
nord passt premium scannt zum beispiel
das internet kontinuierlich nach deinen
daten ab und findet heraus ob diese
nicht möglicherweise gelegt wurden und
als dies der fall sein sollte warnt es
sich so dass du rechtzeitig reagieren
und die gefahr bannen kannst bevor
schlimmeres unglück hereinbricht aber
das beste an der ganzen sache für die
visual pretty comedy hat nord cars eine
ganz besondere aktion in petto einen
ganzen monat kostenlose nutzung plus ein
sonderangebot für dich über das duales
erfährst wenn du den link nord
schrägstrich visual politik aufrufs
denen ich die natürlich auch in die
beschreibung unter diesem video gepackt
haben natürlich kannst du alles in ruhe
und verbindlich und völlig ohne risiko
ausprobieren der nordpark kommt mit
einer 30 tägigen geld zurück garantie
dass es sich bis dahin nicht von seinen
vorzügen überzeugen sollte so und nun
zurück auf den balkan und zur
beantwortung unserer fragen warum war
serbien in der vergangenheit so ein
pulverfass was ist eigentlich während
der jugoslawienkriege passiert und warum
betont putin diese immer wieder in
seinen reden wie so oft werden wir diese
fragen klären indem wir zuerst einen
schnellen blick in die geschichte werfen
also aufgepasst
[Musik]
jugoslawien gas land der schublade
jahrhundertelang war der balkan der
puffer und spielball zwischen zwei
imperien dem der habsburger und dem der
osmanen erst ende des 19 jahrhunderts
erlangt die serben ihre unabhängigkeit
von der türkischen herrschaft und
bildeten ihr eigenes königreich wobei es
damals allerdings noch einige gebiete
mehr umfasste als heute so lebten damals
nicht nur serben in serbien um wohl
umgekehrt auch nicht alles haben im
neuen königreich serbien lebten das ist
allgemein eine schwierigkeit des balkans
viele ethnien leben dort auf relativ
engem raum zusammen und ihre
siedlungsgebiete sind oft über
staatsgrenzen hinweg fragmentierte und
miteinander verwoben nicht alle haben
unterschiedliche sprachen oder
religionen
doch spätestens seit dem siebten
jahrhundert haben alle ihr eigenes
nationalgefühl vieles herben lebten zb
in bosnien herzegowina einer ehemals
osmanischen provinz die sich österreich
ungarn 108 unter dubiosen umständen
offiziell einverleibt hatte das war
grund genug für den nationalisten
gavrilo princip im sommer 1914 in
österreichischen erzherzog franz
ferdinand den thronfolge der k & k
monarchie zu erwarten
richtig ich spreche vom attentat von
sarajewo dem ersten auslöser der juli
krise und damit des ersten weltkriegs
denn daraufhin erklärte
österreich-ungarn dem könig rechts herr
die in den krieg und setzte damit einen
fatalen dominoeffekt in gang der durch
die aktivierung all jener
militärbündnisse ausgelöst wurde die in
den jahrzehnten zuvor in europa geknüpft
worden waren zuerst sprang russland ins
herrn zur seite und damit nahm das
verhängnis seinen lauf wie entstand
ersten weltkrieg auf der seite der
sieger das bedeutete dass das königreich
sein territorium beträchtlich erweitern
konnte damit wurde ein vereinigtes
königreich der slawen realität ein
jugoslawien womit leute die gavrilo
princip hierzu setzt indirekt doch noch
erreicht hatten aber denkt dran die
slawen sind in viele verschiedene medien
aufgeteilt und nicht alle von ihnen
waren sich so sicher ob sie wirklich im
selben staat leben wollten neben serbien
gehörten zu diesen ersten jugoslawien
noch die heutigen staaten slowenien
kroatien und im kosovo mazedonien sowie
bosnien und herzegowina dabei hatten
einige von ihnen in der österreichisch
ungarischen armee gegen die serben
gekämpft und dass nicht alle von ihnen
so glücklich waren teil jugoslawiens zu
werden sieht man etwa daran dass die
kroaten während des zweiten weltkriegs
die achsenmächte unterstützten um ihr
eigenes unabhängiges land zu schaffen so
entstand übrigens eines der
blutrünstigsten regimes der geschichte
die ustascha angeführt von ante pavelic
einem verbündeten adolf hitlers
nebenbei bemerkt wir wollen hier nicht
in die unappetitlichen details gehen
aber den oster war so barbarisch das
sogar liegt deutsche gestapo ihre taten
scharf verurteilte aber das ist ein
thema für ein anderes video doch die
ustascha hatte zum glück nicht lange
bestand nach dem italien sich aus dem
krieg zurück zog gewann allmählich die
jugoslawischen partisanen nicht nur in
kroatien zu dem ganzen land die oberhand
bei dies nach diesen handelt es sich
zumeist vor allem gegen ende des krieges
um kommunisten und ihren anführer seht
ihr gerade auf dem bildschirm
josip broz besser bekannt als tito er
machte sich daran die verschiedenen
völker des balkans wieder zum einen
jugoslawien zu vereinen doch diesmal
nicht als monarchie sondern unter der
idee des sozialismus
auf diese weise entstand die föderative
republik jugoslawien die sich ab 1963
auch sozialistische föderative republik
nannte um die verschiedenen ebenen des
balkans zusammenzuhalten band tito sie
in je eigenen teilrepubliken im
vereinigten staaten ein
im alten jugoslawien sorgte die
unterdrückung durch die gross serbische
kapitalisten clique für wirtschaftliche
ausbeutung der unterdrückten völker
immer neuen sozialistischen jugoslawien
hat die reale gleichberechtigung aller
nationalitäten aus einer nationalen
gruppe unmöglich gemacht eine andere
wirtschaftlich auszubeuten josip broz
tito und ich weiß was ihr denkt als
gutes kommunistisches land war
jugoslawien doch ein satelliten moskaus
nicht wahr nun ganz und gar nicht
jugoslawien hat sich dank des tapferen
partisanenkampf selbst befreit anders
als in anderen osteuropäischen ländern
konnten so die befreier der roten armee
nicht mit ihren schlagenden argumenten
gegenleistungen für die befreiung
einfordern und tito lehnte so auch bald
jede einmischung aus moskau ab
tatsächlich hatten es die slawen unter
allen kommunistischen ländern europas
die meiste zeit des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts am besten sie kommt mit
beiden blöcken geschäfte machen sowohl
mit kapitalisten als auch mit
kommunisten
das land befand sich so gesehen nicht
hinter dem eisernen vorhang mit ihnen
die soz ostdeutschland polen die
tschechoslowakei und ungarn von der
freien welt abgeschnitten hatten dennoch
war die usa in ein sozialistisches land
eine sozialistische föderation um genau
zu sein in der jede teilrepublik ihr
eigenes parlament oder ein hohes maß an
autonomie besaß entscheidungen die das
ganze land betreffen wurden gemeinsam
von einem rad getroffen in den jede
teilrepublik einen vertreter entsandt
und zumindest während titus lebzeiten
war jugoslawien ein verhältnismäßig
stabiles und nicht armes land vor allem
wohl deswegen weil man sich bald von der
planwirtschaft abwandte und eine
sozialistische marktwirtschaft einen
sogenannten konkurrenz sozialismus
einführte diesel machte jugoslawien
lange zum wirtschaftlich stärksten land
institute osteuropa dies änderte sich
jedoch nach titos tod im jahr 2080
deutlich ab da geriet die buslinien in
eine verheerende wirtschaftskrise wozu
auch eine hyperinflation von
venezolanischen ausmaß gehört ja und da
ein punkte sich auch die jugoslawische
völkerfreundschaft als oberflächliche
schönen wetter beziehung denn wenn alles
rund läuft alle das gefühl haben dass es
ihnen nach und nach besser geht und die
wirtschaft punkt sind alle ganz tolle
miteinander befreundet ich haben die
kroaten die slowenen die kosovaren
unsere weiter doch erst wenn das schöne
wetter in einen ungemütlichen sturm
umschlägt merkt man wer die wahren
freunde sind suite8 machte sich breit
und plötzlich ist die regierung nicht
nur schuld an der wirtschaftlichen
misere sondern auch 100 anderen dingen
über die man zuvor geschwiegen hatte
solche vorwürfe sind oft gerechtfertigt
doch menschen neigen eben auch dazu
sündenböcke zu suchen und in einem
vielvölkerstaat zeigt man da leicht auf
den nachbarn
in den späten 80er jahren war besonders
das kosovo ein echtes pulverfass die
kosovo-serben fühlten sich von der
albanischen bevölkerungsmehrheit
unterdrückt und an der spitze des kosovo
und seiner kommunistischen partei
standen die kosovo albaner denen darf
man davor nur im sinne der eigenen
ethnie zu handeln der konflikt war
bereits auf den straßen zu spüren und um
die lage zu beruhigen schickte die kp
serbiens einen mann slobodan milosevic
und die kosovo-serben sagten zu ihm haye
verteidigen bitte unsere rechte in die
kosovo-albaner schikanieren und
[Applaus]
was soll ich sagen sie haben mehr getan
milosevic wandte sie sich vom
kommunisten zum astreinen nationalisten
darfst stieß unter der serbischen
bevölkerung durchaus auf begeisterung
und idealen nutzer 89 wurde er präsident
serbiens eine seiner ersten maßnahmen
war es die autonomie der der jurist
erwischen de facto aber ziemlich
unabhängigen provinzen kosovo und wollte
ihn zu beseitigen indem er ihre stimme
in jugoslawischen rat neutralisierte
angesichts der macht die die serbischen
nationalisten anhäuften entschieden sich
die reichsten teilrepubliken
jugoslawiens slowenien und kroatien ihre
unabhängigkeit zu erklären und so begann
eine verheerende serie und kriegen
[Musik]
die jugoslawienkriege
die erste teilrepublik die unabhängig
wurde war slowenien
da nur weniges herben in slowenien
lebten gab es keine größeren reaktionen
nun ja es gab schon einen
unabhängigkeitskrieg mit jugoslawien
aber der dauerte nur zehn tage der fall
kroatien hingegen war ganz anders
gelagert denn dort lebt auch eine
erhebliche zahl an zepp belgrad schickte
die jugoslawische armee um die
unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen der kroaten
mit gewalt zu unterdrücken der
kroatische unfähigkeit krieg dauert der
jahrelang und bei ein ziemliches blutbad
aber nichts im vergleich zu bosnien
[Musik]
womit wir es hier zu tun haben war
nichts als ein totales und brutales
chaos vieler beteiligter akteure
grob gesagt waren im bosnien-krieg drei
teils miteinander verfeindete parteien
beteiligt innerhalb von bosnien und
herzegowina kämpften die
bevölkerungsgruppen von bosniaken und
bosnischen serben gegeneinander die
einen sind überwiegend muslime die
anderen orthodoxe christen die bosniaken
wurde teils von den kroaten unterstützt
heißt aber auch bekämpft die bosnischen
serben wurden natürlich von serbien bzw
dem was von jugoslawien noch übrig
geblieben war unterstützt darüber hinaus
waren kroatiens herren ohnehin schon
verfeindet da sie ja schon im kroatien
krieg gegeneinander gekämpft hatten ihr
seht also ein wirklich großes und leider
auch schrecklich ist durcheinander zudem
versteht er ist auch warum sie vorhin
von den jugoslawienkrieg allen
gesprochen haben im plural aber
konzentrieren wir uns auf das was in
diesem video wesentlich ist die
bosnischen serben waren zunächst sehr
erfolgreich und ging so weit dass sie
ihre eigene unabhängige republik
gründeten die republica srpska in diesem
zusammenhang kam es zur belagerung von
sarajevo an die sich viele von euch
sicher noch aus den nachrichten erinnern
so diesen zeitpunkt verhängte die uno
eine flugverbotszone
und wer hat den luftraum bostons
verteidigt ganz genau die nato 194 haben
nato kampfflieger so bis zu vier
bosnisch-serbische flugzeuge
abgeschossen doch das war noch nicht der
eingriff den putin vorhin meinte denvers
russland damals dazu gesorgt nun im
kreml hat man kaum protestiert jelzin
hatte im jahr davor sein eigenes
paradies aufgelöst und musste sich um
andere dinge kümmern das erkläre sind
aussagen wie diese
[Musik]
das bosnische dilemma jetzt schien als
hätten die angriffe einzustellen die
scharf formulierte erklärung des kreml
chef zeigt dass sich die haltung
gegenüber den langjährigen verbündeten
geändert hat doch das sah man in
jugoslawien nicht als grund den krieg zu
beenden dazu war die lage viel zu
verfahren und das änderte sich auch
nicht nachdem sich die bosniaken und
bosnischen kroaten gegen die serben
verbündet hatten letztere hatten einfach
die oberhand und waren am gewinnen doch
das begann sich 1995 zu ändern
die bosnischen kroaten erhielten
unterstützung durch die kroatische armee
die gewalt eskalierte nun zunehmend in
diese zeit fällt etwa das von bosnischen
serben verübten massaker von srebrenica
der größten völkermord des bosnienkriegs
als die dinge sehr hässlich wurden
startet die nato die operation der
leverage ford eine dreiwöchige luft
anfange dass ihr die bossen
schlossherren zu verhandlungen zwar die
großen protestierten sagen aber ein dass
dies der einzige weg war den krieg zu
beenden und weitere gräueltaten an
zivilisten zu verhindern so beteiligte
sich moskau sogar gemeinsam mit dem
westen an der aushandlung des dayton
abkommens welches den krieg beendet
endlich konnten die balkanländer
aufatmen jedoch nicht alle für die
serben war das abkommen von dayton so
etwas die die serbische version des
versailler vertrags der wie damals in
deutschland den nationalismus an heisst
bosnische serben lehnen dayton abkommen
ab und gefährden die vereinbarungen doch
damit ist die geschichte noch nicht zu
ende denn die ruhe auf dem balkan
dauerte nur bis
1998 dann begann der nächste krieg in
die reihe der jugoslawienkriege diesmal
zwischen den jugoslawischen streitkräfte
und dem kosovo albanern die unabhängig
von serbien werden wollten jugoslawien
wurde damals unter dem titel
bundesrepublik noch immer von milosevic
beherrschen
der westen bestrafte ihn mit
internationalen sanktionen für seine
unterdrückung im kosovo diese zeigten
jedoch keine wirkung also zwang die nato
belgrad von verhandlungen über die
unabhängigkeit des kosovo die aber
weitgehend ergebnislos blieben und hier
kommen wir endlich zu jenen
bombardements von denen wladimir putin
vorhin gesprochen hat an diesem punkt
nämlich entschied sich die nato
jugoslawien ohne die zustimmung der uno
anzugreifen die bombardierungen dauerte
nur zweieinhalb monate und wurden von
russland scharf verurteilt am ende
kapitulierte milosevic und der kosovo
wurde so eine akte ein protektorat nach
einigen jahren erklärte er schließlich
mit zustimmung des westens seine
unabhängigkeit dieses völkerrechtlich
nicht ganz einwandfreie vorgehen nutzte
putin dann einige jahre später um die
annexion der grill zu rechtfertigen
[Musik]
die russischen streitkräfte beteiligten
sich damals aber internationalen
kontingents das dienstwägen im kosovo
sicherstellen sollte vor ort handelten
sie aber vom rest vertrieben wurden
isoliert und ohne gemeinsame
koordination tatsächlich wäre es schon
dabei nach dem ersten bewaffneten
zusammenstoß zwischen russland und der
nato gekommen als die russen den
flughafen von pristina übernahmen
glücklicherweise hat niemand den ersten
schuss abgefeuert doch seitdem herrscht
auf dem balkan ein rechtliches
gleichgewichte kräfte dass jeden moment
zerbröckeln kann und der russische krieg
in der ukraine könnte hier der tropfen
sein der das fass zum überlaufen bringt
[Musik]
liebesgrüße aus moskau
grund für streit gibt es auf dem balkan
wie wir gesehen haben genug und seitdem
russland auf der krim fakten geschaffen
hat beobachtet man seit einigen jahren
ein ständiges aufrüsten in der region
zum beispiel hat serbien seither seine
investitionen in die verteidigung um 70
prozent auf 1,4 milliarden dollar pro
jahr erhöht zufall wohl kaum
dies hätten waren gerade erst wieder auf
großer einkaufstour von airbus haben sie
zum beispiel unlängst 2 295 mehrzweck
kriegsflugzeuge bestellt mit israel
haben sie über den kauf von
panzerabwehrraketen und mit der türkei
über kampfdrohnen verhandelt dazu hat
belgrad auch chinesische drohen
russische hubschrauber und ein
französisches boden-luft-raketen system
gekauft nebenher haben dann noch
russland und weißrussland den letzten
jahren 10 29 kampfflugzeuge gespendet
[Musik]
außerdem schenkte wir kreml seinen
freunden auf dem balkan 30 panzer und
gepanzerte mannschaftstransporter und
verkaufte ihnen ein luftabwehrsystem
doch die serben sind mit ihrem
ambitionierten rüstungsprogramm nicht
alleine denn kroatien hat zum beispiel
black hawk hubschrauber aus den usa
erhalten einige länder des ehemaligen
jugoslawien rüsten sich stärker auf als
andere aber unterm strich tun dies alle
allen voran eben servieren die dortige
regierung gibt mehr für ihre arme aus
als albanien bosnien montenegro der
kosovo und mazedonien zusammengenommen
[Musik]
für sich genommen würde das vielleicht
wenig bedeuten doch im letzten herbst
schickte belgrad bloß wegen einer
kleinen meinungsverschiedenheit mit dem
kosovo kampfflugzeuge in die nähe der
grenze und satte fahrzeuge ein um seine
ehemalige provinz einzuschüchtern doch
damit nicht genug denn noch unruhiger
ist der starke nationalistische ton den
die serbische regierung bisher besonders
während des wahlkampfs angeschlagen hat
das folgende etwa hat der innenminister
alexander will ihn auf der so genannten
versammlung aller stern gesagt die ende
mai diesen jahres stattfand
derartige anspielungen auf die schaffung
einer serbischen welt werden von allen
ländern in der region in denen es eine
große serbische minderheit gibt mit
misstrauen betrachtet es besteht nun mal
die befürchtung dass die
wiederauferstandene idee eines
großhändlers erneute bewaffnete
konflikte provozieren könnte zudem
wollte serbien bisher keine sanktionen
gegen putins russland verhängen und das
obwohl sie beitrittskandidat der eu sind
[Musik]
man nutze serbien die situation sogar
aus und günstig energie aus russland
geliefert zu bekommen aber dieses thema
die aktuelle situation in serbien seine
beziehung zu russland und auch der
mögliche beitritt zur eu werden die in
einem kommenden video besprechen
eigentlich dürft ihr euch auf eine ganze
serie von videos über den balkan und
ex-jugoslawien freund denn wir denken
dass diese region oft medial
unterrepräsentiert ist und das
vollkommen zu unrecht denn wie die
geschichte gezeigt hat ist sie oft wird
ganz europa schicksalhaft vergesst also
bitte nicht unseren kanal zu abonnieren
und ganz wichtig auch das glöckchen zu
aktivieren denn nur so verpasst ihr
garantiert keines unserer künftigen
videos was uns aber im heutigen video
interessiert wir dürfen nicht vergessen
dass serbien praktisch von der nato
umzingelt ist wo soll die also eine
mögliche bedrohung liegen nun ja
mindestens zwei nachbarländer sind nicht
in der nato und auch nicht in der eu und
das sind ausgerechnet der kosovo und
bosnien herzegowina der kosovo hat sich
erst 2008 von serbien gelöst und wird
von serbien nicht anerkannt und einen
teil von bosnien herzegowina ist immer
noch die und serben gegründete republik
srpska der werbung bald auch ein video
über bosnien veröffentlichen denn auch
über dieses land gibt es die spannendes
zu sagen zum beispiel ist es ein land
mit drei verschiedenen präsidenten einer
von ihnen milorad dodik gibt aktuell den
ton an doch er ist der anführer der
bosnischen serben und droht damit das
land aufzulösen das tut er schon seit
letzten herbst als er sich mit dem
russischen außenminister lavrov bei
diesem treffen wurde bekannt dass die
bosnischen serben moskau um waffenhilfe
gebeten hatten und folgendes hat dodik
dank über die unabhängigkeit der
republik srpska gesagt
[Musik]
diese fernseher sitzen eben in kreml und
haben vor allem ein strategisches
gesamtbild im auge ein weiterer krieg in
europa wäre ein weg den westen zu
destabilisieren ja genau jenen westen
welche der ukraine momentan hilft sich
im krieg gegen russland zu verteidigen
falls putin also zum schluss kommen
sollte dass dies für seinen feldzug in
der ukraine hilfreich sein könnte ist
nicht auszuschließen dass r bosnien ins
visier nehmen wird oder gar schon ins
visier genommen hat allerdings muss man
auch sagen dass serbien zurzeit wieder
etwas mit russland fremdelt denn es
scheint inzwischen nicht mehr unmöglich
dass das neue kabinett die sanktion nun
doch noch mit trägt nicht zuletzt da man
ist ja bin weiter daran interessiert zu
sein scheint der eu beizutreten aber wie
gesagt das ist ein thema zu dem bald von
uns ein eigenes video erscheinen wird zu
diesen eu beitritts ambitionen würde ein
bewaffneten grenzkonflikt so gar nicht
gut passen dennoch sendet die neue
regierung weiter feindseliges signale
richtung kosovo den weiterhin als
abtrünnige provinz betrachtet und
regierungsvertreter wie milorad dodik
wurde kürzlich wegen ihrer aussagen zur
republica srpska explizit von der eu
genügt die lage bleibt also schwierig
manche analysten sagen dass all dies vor
allem damit zusammen hängt dass dieses
jahr ein wahljahr in bosnien ist und
immer wenn wahlen ins haus steht hören
wird jedes mal das gleiche theater die
serben sagen dass sie die unabhängigkeit
erklären werden die kroaten werden süden
und fordern mehr rechte die bosniaken
sagen dass sie in gefahr sind und sich
vereinigen müssen um zu überleben
genauer gesagt es sind die politiker die
diese dinge sagen die normalen bürger
auf dem balkan machen sich mehr sorgen
darüber wie sie angesichts der inflation
ihren lebensunterhalt hinnen können und
selbst wenn ein krieg ausbrechen würde
gäbe es nun recht begrenzte menschliche
ressourcen die in ihn kennen könnten die
meisten jungen leute haben boston
entweder verlassen oder bereiten sich
darauf vor trotzdem putin könnte alle in
ost verzweiflung über die festgefahrene
lage in der ukraine auf biegen und
brechen versuchen weiter auf dem balkan
zu zündeln und auch wenn kein
flächenbrand 1 stunde wären die folgen
für die stabilität in der region fatale
genau deswegen werden wir die lage in
den nächsten videos näher unter die lupe
nehmen um euch ein in sich
abgeschlossenes komplexes bild der
region zu liefern aber was meint ihr
dazu könnte es russlands schaffen alte
wunden auf dem balkan wieder aufzureißen
könnte es im ehemaligen jugoslawien
wieder krieg geben sollten wir
angesichts dieser bedrohungen und der
erfahrungen in der ukraine die eu balkan
erweiterung schneller vorantreiben wie
immer sind auf eure beiträge und
diskussionen zu diesem thema schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat fast jahr gibt es
wieder einen leichten und freuen und
vergesst das abo mit glöckchen um keines
unserer videos mehr ins abwasser testet
bitte auch unverbindlich das angebot
unseres heutigen sponsor snort pass der
für die visual findet die community eine
ganz besondere aktion bietet einen monat
kostenlose nutzung plus ein
sonderangebot für euch über das ihr
alles erst wenn ihr den link nord pas
punkt com schrägstrich personalpolitik
aufruf den die beschreibung unter diesem
video paket natürlich freuen wir uns
auch jederzeit über eine spende von euch
mit den uns hält dieses projekt
weiterzuführen denn peter link dazu
findet ihr ebenfalls in der beschreibung
unter dem video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]